this capture we'll see the concept of
networks of artificial neurons in
machine learning
so we just saw that the gatehouse
collector was allowed to take a
model that were trying to make a
linear classification so learn
a linear decision area between
the two classes we are trying to separate
in this illustration the points
blacks and blue dots we saw
also the logistic regression and the
logistic regression also goes
learn a hyper plan that separates
two classes the class of wheel the class
1 that will be linear so the
perceptor benefits have same thing
for logistics relegation is that
we do not have to remember the whole
training examples keeps them in
memory once the tax collector has it
logistic regression ended his
training everything you need
it's the vector w to be able to do
a prediction on new examples
the opposite we saw the deco booth more
close neighbor and in physics one illustrates
here is the decision surface
associated with the nearest neighbor cases so
we remember that the kop 3 1 for
classify for example this example ci
could look at the two points the
closer so that's maybe the one
there is this one here
and then she's going to determine the class of
point to predict from the label
of his neighbors so in this case too he
would be classified black because the
birds are dead and so because of that
lacker deco nearest neighbor him his
surface of decisions she is actually
nonlinear so we see so any
this region here here and here too
all the regions that contain
points that would be classified as
being black dots and all the
region in white here that would be the region
where to go points would be classified according to
the class associated with the white point so
we see that the surface between the two
which separates these two regions there actually
it's delimited by a surface
which non linear which is not a straight
hockey and because of that it makes that the
war will break down closer neighbor and
more powerful ie able to
solve problems that are polite
nerves by cons we remember that
the Algerian deco nearest neighbor him
more expensive in memory then hear
calculation if we have accents
which are very serious
because we should be remembered
all the training examples and one
must see we will have to go get
closest neighbors for each
new entry that must be classified this
which would be nice to have some
thing against both that is that
which would not exist to keep all in
memory but who will be able to have a
function of so a decision surface
which will not be linear that will be no
linear and so that's what we will have
in fact with a grog network that's what
motivated me among others the use
networks does not make so here we go
see an example in fact of problems that
is not
it's by amine hermes did it so
general the majority in problems
classifications are not linear
not linearly his parents and
finally we'll see an example that is
super simple then we could have thought
that because it was a simple example
it should be easy class finally
so it's going to be separable number itself
not the case
imagine a classification problem
where we have in trip 2 bits x1 x2 so the
dimension of the doctors in three x
it's going to be a time vector and
only 2 so if we look by
example is a yes it's its x1 editors
the two different years correspond to
beats 0 1
so if we wanted to learn enough
function end so the operator and this
xperia x2 ben we are con it would be
able to take it with a
classifiable actually the point 0
001 and
12 01 savoie 6 016 makes this point here
then 1 06 point here these three points
their are associated with the zero class
while this point here very closely associated
to class 1 since both inputs
on a flat exit of the operator and on
the beats to re-register 1 so we see
that in this case if we are able to
move a straight line between the examples of
the class of euros it is the example of
same classification for the function to
both the operator or because if the
point if the point becomes the
class 1 night rest of class 1 and
him from the a-40 is still able to
go right between the two classes
on the other hand soria does not work
really more complicated than the function
so export a function that returns
who will return 0.6 both goals are
zero or both goals are a dish that
will go back so one of the two quickly and
an island of zero as is the case here
and here
so what if we will not be able to
to pass a straight line that would allow
separate on one side the points associated with
ranking of enough class points then
how exactly do we solve
this problem no and well what we
could do in fact it's transformed
the entrance to get a new
representation or in this space there to
the data will be linearly its
parents in that function etc be in
son we could have done is
replace x1 by the operator is
applied on the former listener then there
the excision input by replace it with
the operator
point therefore applied to the input x1 x2 if
we do here so we have our problem
represented by x1 and x2 on my two
axes and that I replace problem where
the x-axis must be the operator
historic belt access them there
maybe the operator applied on
the operator or applied on mx1 mx2
because if in fact this point go
become that point there in the new
representation
so actually if I apply the
function is about 1 1
I get as helmsman 1 then
I apply the function or on point 1
I also get for this point there
this new coordinate system is going
to be represented by will be here
in the new the new
nancy representation I do the same
thing with xperia 0,10 of gas 0 I get
found 1,100 also and then if I
take these two points here so 1 0
and 0,1
the value for the operator or vote is
from 1
but the value for the operator he is going
to be zero so these two points there
will end up here we notice in
this new representation loeb I
am able to actually separate but
two classes we also notice that we have
seen that the operator or then the operator
and it's your operator that we could
learn with a linear model
for example we could take it with
a logistic regression which is so
Spirulina is it so it suggests
that if I would like if I wanted
learn by whose function xo-1
because I could actually
firstly to take a regression
logistics for the function or a
logistic regression for function
and then give yourself the exit
marie gassion logistics input
to another logistic regression that
she will learn what's left to
do that ie the export function and
so basically the induction behind
the usefulness of neural networks
artificial
so what we're going to do is we're going
learn the weights of a classified
linear but it's classy to come
she will apply on a
transformation of the input that will make
the problem
herman his parents so we're going to have in
made several logistic regression that
are going to be a dc by the industry so here
I would have another logistic aggression
who would be connected with my entries
but even between here and it would be j -
years I'll have another here for d + 1
so I'll have many like that
are they going to be connected with a
other logistic regression but which is going
take as input these calculated values
at the logistic regression output of the
previous layer of regression
logistics and if we actually see each
of those logistic regression there as a
kind of neurons where there are forces
connections between neurons there and
neurons of a previous layer
but under this representation there
can interpret the kind of calculation done
by this model there as a calculation done by
a neural network but that is
artificial so with neurons
artificial
so that's our it's an example of
neural networks but also here we have
a single layer we will say that this
left there she is hidden so here all
the neurons we will find here all
logistic regressions we will find
here did that going to match a
layer of neurons that are said to hide
because we do not know exactly
value that must be modeled when
training to do everything we go
to be able to give as sign to
training is what values ​​we
would like to have
at the exit of the network therefore does not render to the
any end of the calculation here we will want
that h2x acquired the output of this wall to our
price calculations say well the target there
associate with my input x and for his
neurons did it we want it
discover a representation and we
past the sheath we go to those two
found with the descent of gasa we went
found the representation too that is going
to facilitate problems
make here this regression of
logistic regression ci that will tempt
she to predict iker
so yes that actually prevents us
to have several coaches hidden in one
example here we would have a first
layer hidden here a second layer
hidden here then finally we would have a
exit those who would try to predict there
I will use the notation in the
book of abductees go each
neurons that is in the silk
the layer here that we will call the layer
entrance so we do that it's okay
to correspond ex françois caron
correspond to x2 so its neurons
their are going to be clues and with the same
age index that neurons the first
mowing hide the second hidden layer
of the third and one goes one city hall
like that 1 2 3 4 5 6 is so of the
entrance layer until the race
will call the output layer then we
will note acts as being the activity of the
I like to go to our network and that
it's going to be like the
input and output neurons and between
others we will see that to vote galaxy
so at 1 is equal to sixteen then to 2t
gala x2 I also noted
indjic as being the activity of the gym
neurons but at 20 non-linearity
logistics
so i'm going to have that hadji is equal to
the logistic or sigmoid function
applied on the variable that I call
angie then in j make it worth
simply corresponds to the products of
connections between neurons j with the
neurons from the previous layer 1 from here
paris x the activity of neurons in the
previous layer
so the neurons at there is so what we
going to have here actually is that according
this notation there if there is no
connections between neurons neurology on
will assume that w yj is equal to zero
so we observe here that w13 is the
connection weight between a1 and a3
since art is equal to aix france and the
correction between the first entry and
the neuron hidden here w14 it's going to be the
selection to
between 1 and 4 and a website so w500
with the neural collection to the one who
is in the second layer hide and the
output neuron that we will note at a
forgiveness incident is also attentive to this
that if your correspondents our h2x and
the prediction we will make for our
entrance then this is the description of
of the neural network model
artificial